ja ich bin diesmal auf den punkt sowie
millionen deutsche das sehen ich habe
die schnauze voll ich habe die schnauze
voll von einer sozialen
ungerechtigkeit und unserem land und von
einer heuchlerischen doppelmoral der
politik denn wenn man etwas von anderen
fordert opferbereitschaft fordert dann
muss man bei sich selbst anfangen und
das bedeutet vor allem dass man auch im
kanzleramt start nicht abschaltet auch
die klimaanlage runtergedreht und vor
allen dingen einen kanzleramts baustopp
denn wenn man etwas fordert muss man es
vormachen und die menschen und das spiel
jeden tag hunderte von e-mails sind
verzweifelt haben angst alles zu
verlieren und wir helfen gerne aber wir
müssen dabei aufpassen dass wir uns
nicht selbst verlieren und unser land
dabei zerstören und das quartier gerade
passiert ist gefährlich und es ist ein
kochkessel für etwas was er noch den
straßen weiter geht und ich komme aus
einer ecke wo gewalt normales und ich
möchte das nicht in unserem land aber
was hier passiert auf den rücken und den
kosten der bürger muss aufhören aber
möchten sie diese symbolpolitik für
unser land sie haben gesagt da muss das
licht ausgemacht werden und dann hier
und warum die politik so heute aber
wollen sie generell für dieses land das
mit dem finger gezeigt wird wenn ich das
licht aus hat weil wenn sie das von der
politik verlangen dann verlangen sie das
ja auch eigentlich vom bürger also
grundsätzlich ist es okay wenn man sagt
wir können sparen so sehen wo wir sparen
aber es gibt natürlich grenzen also
grundsätzlich müssen wir schon gucken
wie weit müssen wir sparen runterdrehen
und was erwartet man also wenn ein
ministerpräsident aus baden württemberg
sagt wir sollen waffen benutzen da frag
ich mich wissen sie machen sie noch ein
bisschen eiswürfel in die waschlappen
packte sich die ihn auf den kopf
vielleicht hilft ja ein bisschen ein
bisschen verrückter zu gehen weil so
viel scheiße kann man ja nur noch lachen
aber das ist ja nicht zum lachen sondern
ich habe so viele menschen die angst
haben alles verlieren wir haben 1000
bald hier mehr gas wir haben 1000
prozent mehr mehr sturm was ist denn
dann wird deutlich sagen die müssen sich
darauf vorbereiten 1500 euro für
stromrechnungen zu sparen menschen haben
noch nicht mal 1500 euro im monat was
für eine gekühlte scheiße reden die da
wie weltfremd sind die seite eurer
wandlitz blase eingesperrt in einem
anderen universum kommt man zurück auf
der erde und vielleicht sollten wir euch
alle mal dann erinnern wer hier das land
eigentlich führte sind wir ihr seid
angestellter von uns verdammt nochmal
hier arbeitet für uns und vielleicht
wird es mal zeit durch zu kehren und
dass er mal auf dem fenster öffnet das
ein bisschen durchzug habe dass ihre
gehirne wieder funktionieren und da bin
ich sehr sehr deutlich und ich weiß von
so vielen zuschriften dass die menschen
nicht mehr können und dass dieses land
langsam nicht mehr aushält was hier
passiert herr borowka spüren sie auch
die wut der bürger ja natürlich das
bekomme ich auch alles mit bei uns ist
es ja so mit unserem kleinen
gemeinnützigen verein oder worauf die
suchtprävention und suchthilfe die
menschen melden sich sie haben alle mehr
probleme sie wissen nicht sie haben
existenzangst
versagensängste und das ist das problem
was sie jeden tag immer mit bekomme
immer mehr menschen rutschen ab in die
sucht ja und sie wissen nicht mehr wie
sie das normale leben bewältigen sollen
und das ist ein riesenproblem für uns
als kleiner voll gemeinnütziger verein
das aufzufangen wir sind angetreten
damals und wollte nun zum kinder aus
suchtkranken familien kümmern wir
wollten uns um sportler kümmern die
probleme haben inzwischen ruft jeder bei
uns an der ruhigen ganz andere wegen
allen anderen problemen und wie gesagt
der herr politiker der journalist der
maschinenschlosser alles ist da und wir
haben einfach wir sind nur zwei leute
und da können sie sich vorstellen was
ich da tag und nach zu tun habe seit ein
paar jahren und das ist auch für mich
der abstand und wir fragen bei dem
politiker hier in der runde er weist
auch wenn sie das hier hören die sie
wird also ich spreche ja schon laut
hersteller schreit ja schon richtig
seine wut hier raus wie sehen sie das
dann würden sie zustimmen dass die
politik zu abgehoben ist nicht mehr
genug bei den leuten oder wird das ist
ja völlig falsch gesehen von herr stahl
und herr borowka na ja herr stahl ist
jemand der gerne zuspitzt und dann ist
ja auch laut und sehr bestimmt in seinem
auftreten so kennen wir ihn und so wird
er von vielen auch geschätzt ich würde
noch gar nicht von wut sprechen wollen
an dem zusammenhang sondern ich glaube
es gibt eine große sorge und große angst
was kommt da auf uns zu weil es noch
keiner abschätzen kann so richtig und es
wird viele menschen sehr hart treffen
ich glaube das muss man als politiker
dann auch aussprechen das ist sehr
schwierige monate sind die vor uns
liegen kommt der winter wir wissen nicht
wie sieht es mit energie sorgen aus wie
wird die gasversorgung lager aussehen im
winter werden wir noch warme wohnungen
haben reicht das was wir an strom haben
um dann auch gegebenenfalls mit strom zu
heizen herum dann mal den radiator
anzuschalten um die wohnung warm zu
bekommen unser netz ist da nicht
wirklich für ausgestattet momentan das
muss man auch sagen wenn man jetzt
anfängt atomkraftwerke abzuschalten
diese situation dann wird es kalt und
dunkel in deutschland in diesem winter
und da hat politik eine gestalten rolle
und da muss man aufpassen muss zum einen
für eine versorgungssicherheit sorgen
wir müssen gucken dass unser stromnetz
funktioniert dass das aushält weg und so
kam er ausgangs ist die politik zu
abgehoben der vorwurf ist jäger kleinem
raum von der seite da ist die politik
nicht mehr bei den bürgern es stimmt
dass ich glaube nicht ich glaube nicht
wenn die sorgen würden sie nicht wie
eine kirche oder wissen sie also ich
weiss es für mich ich kann ja nicht für
die politiker sprechen ich kann nur für
mich sprechen und ich hier sehe die
sorgen der nachbarn meiner freundin
meiner bekannten ich weiß dass ganz
viele menschen die nicht in der lage
sein werden eine nachzahlung der
nebenkosten von 2000 euro auf einmal auf
den tisch zu legen das sind leute wurde
disbu am ende des monats auf anschlag
ist und die sollen dann auf einmal 2000
3000 euro wir wissen noch nicht was bei
dem gas auf uns zukommt dann auf den
tisch legen können das wird eine große
soziale feuerprobe für unsere
gesellschaft wie wir damit umgehen und
da ist die politik in der verantwortung
das ordentlich zu gestalten wir müssen
uns um die kümmern die es überhaupt
nicht können von der leistung her wir
müssen aber aufpassen dass die mitte der
gesellschaft liche abgehängt wird weil
das ist dann wird es richtig gefährlich
in diesem land wenn wir die arbeiten der
mitte der gesellschaft verlieren weil
sagen ich werde von der politik im stich
gelassen ich kann meine rechnungen nicht
mehr bezahlen wie soll ich das machen
das sind um summen die auf mich zukommen
und da muss die politik der antwort
finden ich habe sie heute noch nicht
dabei das sage ich ihnen auch ganz
ehrlich aber das ist die herrliche heute
bei ihrer pc regiert ja mit ja aber wir
müssen natürlich uns in so eine
situation auch lisa herantasten ja das
ist eine situation die wir so noch nicht
hatten in der bundesrepublik deutschland
und der nachkriegsgeschichte es ist eine
feuerprobe die wir so auch noch nicht
hatten bela ist die antwort für dich
zufriedenstellen na ja wir haben hier
zwei im grunde pole aber die bundes
gleiche ausdrucken eigentlich die die
sorge der menschen was passiert wenn wir
immer guter zahlen zahlen zahlen wenn es
keine entlastung gibt und wenn die
menschen nicht mehr wissen wo sie es
hernehmen soll und da ist es richtig
dass es da natürlich besorgnis gibt und
ängste und sorgen und wut auch was
passiert und wie ich damit umgehe und
eine ratlosigkeit was ich tue das ist ja
dass ich diese wut jetzt schon oder
diese sorgen jetzt schon artikulieren wo
die menschen ja nur die sorgen nur die
sorgen haben außer an der
zapfsäule trotz dieses entlastung wie im
grunde ja keine gefühlte war und auf der
anderen seite diese großen hemmer die
nachzahlung ja erst noch kommen also da
kann man sich vorstellen was da los sein
wird deswegen bin ich da fest von
überzeugt wir brauchen lösungen und wir
brauchen klare lösungen und alles was
wir heute wieder gehört haben schöne
grüße nach meseberg zu der klausur die
da stattgefunden hat reicht natürlich
nicht also man kann nicht sagen wer
diese rechtliche rundfunk sagt wuchtig
nicht konkret genug der das schon sagt
dann ist das ein richtiger hammer also
nein ganz im ernst also da ich sagen ich
kann euch die mehrwertsteuer ein
bisschen und dann gebe ich euch 300 dann
müsst ihr aber wieder etwas versteuern
weil wir können euch nicht direkt
überweisen und der arbeitgeber zahlen
deshalb aus das versteht doch kein
mensch mehr das reicht auch nicht diese
belastung die sie genannt haben der
überhaupt runter zu setzen deswegen muss
man drei sachen tun im grunde man muss
diesen gaspreis deckeln erlebt man sich
den spanischen ministerpräsidenten ein
der das gemacht hat nach nach suhr
von der ampel regierung aber er hat's
gemacht gesagt hier ist schluss und den
rest zahlen wir das zweite ist man muss
eigentlich diesen strompreis entkoppeln
vom gas die hängen ja zusammen bin der
gaspreis nach oben geht der hilft mir
auch der radiator nicht
wenn wir nämlich so viel verbraucht und
man muss natürlich sich klar machen ich
meine sie haben es erwähnt deutschland
ist ein industrieland deutschland ist
ein industrieland was energie braucht
wir schöpfen mehr aus unserer
industriefertigung als jedes andere land
in europa das heißt wir werden ob es
einem gefällt oder auch nicht auf
absehbare zeit auch ein dritter
energieträger brauchen weil wind und
sonne reichen
dafür und das kann sonst wo her dass
kein gas sein sonst woher aber das muss
man auch hand schaffen dann auch und das
sind die drei singe deckel drauf
entkopplung und sich damit abfinden dass
wir auf absehbare zeit das wird keiner
keiner umweltaktivistin gefeiert aber
noch einen zusätzlichen energieträgern
der frist auf das klingt eigentlich
haben ganz guten plan warum setzt die
ampel das nicht einfach um bilder einer
kommen bestimmt gerne vor bayern stellen
vor
ja ich denke was die ampel gemacht hat
sind ja schon erste gute schritte ich
meine wir haben entlastungspaket in der
ampel entschlossen dies in den letzten
jahren so nicht gab mit einem
gesamtvolumen von 30 milliarden was
wuchtig heißt kann ich ihnen heute auch
noch nicht übersetzen das ist ja noch
recht neu aber ich gehe davon aus wenn
wir mit so einem doch eindrucksvollen
wort nach draußen gehen das ist jetzt
nicht mehr um kleine cent beträge gehen
wird sondern dass hier noch mal eine
große entlastung auch für die mitte der
gesellschaft kommen wird und das muss
ich auch tun ich muss die menschen die
arbeiten gehen jeden tag aufstehen geld
verdienen auch geld wieder geben und in
die möglichkeit geben ihr zu
wirtschaften und selbst herr der lage zu
sein aber darum ist entlastung nennen
ein gutes ein guter ansatz hier handeln
sandra nicht so entlasten wie die
menschen entlastet werden müssten das
was ich meinen also wir reden ja hier
wirklich von der entlastung ich bis ein
tropfen auf dem heißen stein wir reden
hier von 1500 euro mehrere drei der vier
mal soviel und ihr kommt man mit 300
euro ein euro ticket oder was und dann
und das ist das was ich meinen also ist
es total er eine parallelwelt natürlich
weniger monat zwischen 10 und 40 tausend
euro verdiene dann gar nicht natürlich
das vielleicht nicht nachvollziehen der
gemeinde hinter und hier arbeitet habe
dann weiß ich gleich und ängste und nöte
und sorgen sind gekappt hat alles getan
ich habe eine private insolvenz hat
alles schon hinter mir und ich sehe die
nöte kennedy schon einiger machen bei
der prävention aufklärung habe jeden tag
mit diesen menschen zu tun habe dies so
wir kennen das sind auch gute politik
wird wenig aber die viele von denen die
stolzen die vergessen hatte gestern
gesagt haben und könnte ich morgen nicht
mehr daran erinnern die sind vollkommen
abgehoben und wissen sie wo bleiben sie
denn ich habe kein problem einen herrn
scholz und ihrem prozent über zu stehen
aber dafür haben sie nicht den arsch in
der hose sich wirklich mal mit leuten
auseinanderzusetzen die auch mal
wirklich konnte jemand wirklich was
seine sind außer bier kann sehr schnell
bist du schon sagst du deine arbeit war
und wenn ich meine antwort das gibt
selbst gar nichts die schreiben auch
nicht leuten wie mir zurück weil dann
gäbe es ja beweise und ich habe eine
million volle millionen menschen von
reichweite wirkte transportieren dann
kommt man hier keine antwort nein ich
kann verstehen dass man angst davor hat
aber wenn man sich um diesen posten
diesen mussten haben wollte man hat sich
darum beworben dann füllt diesen posten
auch aus in der krise beweist sich der
charakter und wartet hier sehe im moment
ist einfach nur noch beschämend einfach
nur beschämend und absolut weg von der
insel sauer weil herr scholz und herr
ländern nicht jedem bürger antworten man
sich nicht gegeben
das bestimmt ich nicht jedem bürger aber
ich wäre schon sehr zufrieden das schon
wir haben schwere schon zufrieden wäre
scholz einfach mal fragen von der presse
beantwortet nicht einfach sagen ihr
könnt nicht beantworten mache ich aber
nicht ich wäre schon zufrieden wenn er
stolz die ängste und sorgen der bürger
wichtig nehmen wir noch nicht sagen
würde man sollte die eigenen bürger
nicht so ernst nehmen ich werde das
schon sehr zufrieden wir herr schulz
sich daran erinnern sollte weiter noch
von halben jahr oder von gemacht hat
wenn er mit der größten privatbank
zusammen die die menschen wirklich auf
die straßen gehen werden ich kann nur
eins sagen mehr sagen ja immer so
solange der deutsche serviert und sein
fußball hat so ist er lang ist sehr
genügsam andere länder wären schon
längst da ich kann mir aber gut
vorstellen wenn ich bin ich mal
bezahlbar ist während fernsehen nicht
mehr funktioniert bei der strom- und
teuer ist und da man dann auch noch
friert und die eigenen kinder weinen
dann glaube ich schon dass das maß diese
rote linie diese rot grüne linie weit
überschritten ist und ich kann diese
bundesregierung sehen wir gerade noch
weit entfernt als wenn man sich zum
beispiel energiemonitor derzeit den kann
ich in meinem verehrten schaut dann
sieht man schon sehr klar dass wir
eigentlich über diesen winter schon
wahrscheinlich gut kommen werden also
dieses friedrich ist ja noch nicht ja
sagen ich denke auch zu welchem preis
wie sollen wir das bezahlen wo soll die
kohle her kommen wir können ja mal eins
machen nochmal gut vergessen wir doch
alle mal wie haben stolz er vergisst ja
auch jetzt einfach mal die rechnung zu
bezahlen vergisst wäre das doch allemal
die rechnung zu bezahlen hat wollen sie
machen uns allen den strom abdrehen und
jetzt nochmals andere kommen aus dessen
glauben die menschen können strom auch
nicht mehr bezahlen obwohl es wird auch
entlastungspaket gehen einhausen so wie
sehen eigentlich den kompletten yanar
damals sagen ich sehe hier nicht den
absoluten umsturz arsch das läuft ja
okay ich glaube bloß dass die menschen
die es wirklich am nötigsten brauchen
dabei am wenigsten bekommen und die
jüdischen haben eine gasanlage und dann
wollen wir doch mal klar ich feststellen
er eine gas umlagert von vom
wirtschaftsminister der für wirtschaft
zu ist da muss man doch klar sein wenn
wir so hat schon gesagt dass er jetzt
die gasanlage verändern wird als
supersache das sagt auch mal für dass
der wirtschaftsminister das schon jetzt
in der lage ist zu erkennen dass da
vielleicht heute bescheißen wollen
haufen kohle haben und wir wie liebe
bürger und da zähle ich zu und viele von
ihnen ja auch die sollen ja alles und
wir bürger ja ja ja der eine oder andere
verdient ja nur auch von uns bezahlt
hätte beinahe dazu wir sollen jetzt also
unternehmen die milliarden gewinne
gemacht haben über jahre hinweg wir
müssen sie jetzt über diese krise tragen
damit sie ihre gewinne nicht verlieren
aber wir sind nicht daran beteiligt
gewesen wenn sie gewinne machen ich sind
jetzt schon ein bisschen asozial und ein
bisschen vollkommen daneben ihr habt die
ganze zeit kollege machen sind beteiligt
mit den steuern die unternehmen zahlen
wenn unternehmen viel verdienen geben
sie auch viel applaus der mehr sind die
steuern aber sie investieren ihre idee
auch oft gerne in andere dinge
tochterfirmen et cetera und katzi nennt
auch wieder geld ich würde vor allem
gerne mal eins wissen beisteuern sind
von ja in deutschland daher rechnungen
in version auf den weg legen manche
sachen schon aber müssen so was mich ja
vor allem interessiert ich habe heute
eine eine schlagzeile gesehen wenn man
doch wenn man doch sanktionen schafft
sensation schafft dann sollten jedoch
eigentlich auch nutzen tragen und wenn
ich heute lese sehr das gastro
milliarden rekordgewinne macht dann
würde ich doch mal sagen irgendwann gar
nicht so richtig funktioniert eine frage
hätte ganz egal was ist das eigentlich
für das was wir da kaufen wo kommen wird
wo kommt das her denn vielleicht sind ja
an so clever und kaufen das gas da
drehen es einmal irgendein anderer
catrin und kommt wieder ins unser land
zurück und einfach kommt nur woanders
her und wir zahlen passt sich das gas
wird wenn ich haben wollten so es wird
mehr blut diamanten aus afrika kaufen
aber kaufen sie woanders hier ich will
einfach nur mal wissen er habe am selbst
da wurde nicht von der regierung ab
gelesen sondern durch nord stream 1
wurde s gedrosselt das heißt wir haben
nicht gesagt wir wollen das gas nicht
mehr und darauf verzichtet sondern das
ist eine entscheidung aus russland warum
das gas gerade nicht mehr rauskommt die
beziehen ist und dass man das hier wir
versuchen es absolut und tun es auch
aber weil sie zu ihrer these wir müssen
noch zinsen kaum noch einen ganz kurzen
abschließenden appell zu ihrem thema
innenpolitik bänden ja ich würde ganz
einfach mal sagen lieber politik
vielleicht verlässt der wand blitzt und
die blase und geht nun wirklich zu den
bürgern und als allererstes würde ich
mich für diese arroganz und ignoranz und
diese doppelmoral hier teilweise jetzt
die letzten monate verwahrt einfach mal
entschuldigen und dann einfach mal
bürgernahe politik machen und vor allen
dingen wie wärs denn mal wenn ihr
anstatt euch in so einer krise die
diäten erhöht alle vielleicht mal
überlegen ob wir nicht mal ein bürger
von aufmacht ich weiß ihr habt die
gesetze so geregelt dass man ist ja alle
nicht auf ihr geld verzichten könnt ihr
wart schon clever aber ihr könnt ja
eigentlich mal so ein teil ihres
gehaltes spenden in einem bürgerforum 25
prozent sind weiß man wird so zehn
prozent werden damit die bürger merken
dass wir auch daran beteiligt und nicht
wie eine frau stark zimmermann sagt wir
sollen opfer an phoenix suns
ich wollte den streik werden